Why crack Greg here. And like many of you,
I would love nothing more than a breakdown, the newest film in the MCU,
but of course, due to the bad thing that might not be possible for a very long,
but perhaps a silver lining to this breaking content is the chance to catch our
breaths and consider the future of the MCU.
So we're going to do something different today. Don't worry.
We're not going to get into reckless speculation. Instead.
We're going to ask the question who should be Daniel's 2.0,
and how could our dream villain add the serious smarts to the MCU that we all
deeply crave? Well,
it turns out our topic was actually just cast an ant man,
three that's right. Kang the conqueror. So who is this snazzy dress,
bad guy, other than a potential new PVC pipe player and the blue man group.
And what is his unique multi temporal existence can raise some serious questions
about our own human identity. We'll explain in this wise crack blog on Kang,
the conqueror and the future of the MCU. Oh, and spoil us for the MCU.
Lie ahead as well as potential spoilers for its future.
If we turn out to be profit now, before the breakdown,
I want to let you guys know where you can find some of the in-depth discussions
that go into making videos like this.
Our second channel wise cast has all of our live podcasts,
including show me the meaning culture binge and the squanch,
or show me the meaning. We talked about the Avengers and Spiderman,
and you can bet once a new Marvel film drops,
we're going to be doing an episode. So don't miss out,
click the link in the description to subscribe and keep up with all our deep
dives into the movies and TV shows that you love. Now,
back to the show. Kang is one of Marvel comics,
most regularly appearing villains,
tangling time after time with the likes of the Avengers and fantastic four and
playing a role in a lot of the comics major developments over the years, uh,
time traveling desperate Kang Hills for one of the multi versus many earths or
utopia in the 31st century,
essentially he's like a cross temporal and extra dimensional Gangas con
constantly hopping around time and space in the quest for ever increasing
challenges to his martial arts skill and tactical prowess.
He can handpick the most powerful beings out of the time stream to final his
bath traveled back the weekend.
A society are even whole plans before they know he exists and he controls
vast armies of futuristically armed soldiers.
He's also a scientific genius and a man master strategist, man,
talk about overachiever,
but King is also radically different from most supervillains specifically
because he's not really defined by his conflict with the heroes he fights.
Instead.
He's more so defined by accomplishment as with themselves kangaroo born,
Nathaniel Rich's has adopted many distinct identities over his lifetime,
and this difference might be able to tell us a whole lot about what comes next
for the MCU.
Mostly because Kings unique paths opens the door to exploring all kinds of
questions about identity. See King is less a person,
a more like a period of the thing is life and identity formed through the
experiences and fears he had during a specific portion of his personal timeline.
At other key points,
he creates entirely new entirely conflicting identities for himself
based on lived experiences and anticipations for the future,
like his future incarnation and Morton's guardian of time,
itself and wearer of stylish helmets or his teenage version.
I lad founder of the young Avengers and brazen intellectual property.
But the thing that separates these identities from mere costume changes is their
prolific and very personal use of time travel. You know,
the common rule in time travel story.
He must not see anybody or talk to anybody.
And if you do could have serious repercussions on future events,
do you understand?
Yeah, that one,
neither cane mortars are iron lad cares one iota about this
all three,
go back and forth in their own timelines and various points to influence their
past present or future. As a result,
these identities often come into direct literal conflict with each other
in turn influencing each of their respective developments.
Hell they often have a direct hand in the changes in the Daniel's perceptions
that leads to the creation of a new identity in the first place.
As you can imagine, this gets real confusing real quick.
You only need to look at the amount of rent cons Kings had in the comic is
proof.
This all makes Kang a pretty unique character who offers endless narrative
possibilities and raises lots of questions about identity.
And we think those questions can be best understood by looking at something
called narrative identity theory,
calling by philosopher Paul record the theory posits that identities
aren't locked in fixed,
but a form by an ongoing active process of narrative visitation that we
ourselves engage in.
I simply put our identities are the result of the stories we tell ourselves
about ourselves record pods is that we mold our memories into a cohesive
plot,
just like a screenwriter takes scenes as raw materials to form acts that make a
story. We interpret the events of our past,
through our perceptions of the present,
which leads us to determine which past events are most relevant to who we feel
we are. What's more, we also anticipate potential futures,
which inform our actions in the present.
That's creating new events for us to interpret and add to our story.
The futures we predict is most likely our desire most or are most scared
of provide endings to the story we are creating,
which in turn colors, our interpretation of the past,
like how it's much easier to pick out themes and motifs in a movie.
The second time you watch it with the ending and therefore the complete
narrative in mind in this way,
narrative integrates our reconstructed past our perceived
presence and our imagined futures into one perpetually shifting,
but cohesive story that we tell ourselves. And if the story changes,
if our interpretations of the past or expectations of the future are altered,
then we can integrate them into our stories. Thus altering our identities.
As convoluted as these stories can get Kang,
the conqueror and Mortenson iron lad, the temporarily disparate identities,
that form that Daniel Richards are a great demonstration of narrative identity
theory. Specifically,
these stories explore the interplay between our past present and future
King being the identity we follow most is the present. The more,
this is the future and ironclad is the past and mortars observing all of the
past and future.
And the timeless dimension of limbo actively works against Kang,
his past identity,
but also manipulates our outright changes events to ensure that King always
becomes the mortars. There will be no Marty McFly being here, sir, Kang,
meanwhile,
actively tries to prevent this potential future as a mortis at the same time,
King also travels back in his own timeline to try and spur his teammate self,
to take up all the conquering, even earlier,
attempting to influence his past self,
just as a more than strives to influence him.
This leads his teenage self to rebel against this potential future forming a new
identity as iron lad, hanging out with the Avengers and trying to stop Kang.
Eventually he becomes a straight up superhero and forms the young Avengers as a
result in their multi temporal interactions,
which become crucial to the identity formation of each King and mortis.
An iron land can be seen as literal embodiments of records,
ideas they're heightened forms of the interpretations perceptions and
anticipations that we all make on a daily basis in our own lives made
possible through delicious time, travel, weirdness all together.
They form an overall narrative of their own showing how the same man can be a
superhero supervillain and in an indifferent guardian of time in a single
lifetime narrative identity theory is interesting because it gives us agency
over our own.
Self-conception compare this to a more essential as views like Plato's,
which tie identity to a fixed mostly unchangeable nature.
In Plato's view, people could change to a degree,
but someone born to be a farmer was never going to be a King recurrence is far
from the only philosopher to ask questions about how people can change.
But it's theory can help us understand who we are,
how our identity is formed and how we can shift that identity to become the
person we want to be.
So the complex interplay between King and Mortenson and iron lad mirrors,
the constant process, we engage with informing our own identities.
That's why we're so psyched to see him in the MCU.
And while we reckon he'll be the next big bed after all the next overarching
MCU Villa needs to fill an awfully big pair of boots,
Kings conflict with the mortars and iron lands,
desperate attempt to assert agency over his future,
provide a big dint character arc that makes them distinct from families,
but still matches the massive narrative stakes that the inevitable purple man
brought to the table.
Inevitable.
More than just matching panels.
We think Kang has the potential to address one of the biggest narrative issues.
The MCU faced in the affinity side,
the Matic cohesion based on where the MCU is post end game and what we know
about upcoming projects,
it seems like the nature of identity could be an overarching theme in future MCU
films. What's more,
this theme could help make connections between various characters and across
various worlds. In fact,
we've even had a little taste of this with Spider-Man far from home,
which saw the web shooting high school heartthrob contemplating Tony Stark's
legacy, immense pressure to shift his own identity that,
that of the new iron man by introducing Kang as the new big,
bad Marvel has the opportunity to really tie the larger narrative of the MCU
together around themes of identity, how we form them,
how we adapt them to circumstances outside of our control and how we can
reconcile our past with who we know we can become.
And if the MCU goes in this narrative direction can conserve as an antagonist
alongside the heroes, both camps confronted with the same thematic challenges,
but taken different paths in order to pull it off, though,
they'll have to really commit to developing all three identities.
That means building up King and mortars and iron land over a series of
appearances and having an ongoing macro plot centered around discovering the
full extent of King's cross temporal dickery.
And this complex identity has the potential to make Kang a much more interesting
and nuanced villain that animals don't get us wrong.
We love the big purple snap daddy and his themes of sacrifice and purpose drove
infinity war,
but a stronger Dematic unity within the wider story would be a huge step forward
for the pioneering kind of interwoven narrative.
Marvel's been honing for the past 12 years and by exploring King's personal arc
and interactions with his past and future identities,
Marvel can dig into internal narrative dilemmas as much as they do an external
cosmic beefs, but Hey, maybe we're wrong.
And no one at the NCU brain trust has ever heard of Paul Ricker,
maybe Kang shows up in an man three and dies at the end,
like so many MCU villains with squander potential before him,
even if that's the case, we're still psyched to finally see King in the MCU,
whatever direction Marvel decides to go in.
We're confident in a live up to the legacy they've created thus far. Look,
if we're super off the, with all this Kang stuff,
we're sorry for getting your hopes up, but rest assured,
if we're right about any of this, we'll repost this video until the end of time.
Big thanks to all our patrons for all your support hit that subscribe button.
Like it's your, future self, and as always, thanks for watching peace.
[Inaudible].